so a review of two-man caffeine matt go
ahead and turn around for us please
separate your feet
turn your toes outward
place your hands behind your back don't
move do you understand yes sir
yes
okay we're gonna head that way to my car
do you understand yes sir okay go ahead
and do that now
all right uh
let's say they're getting froggy on you
okay
uh
often a go-to tactic is to just sweep
them but she's handcuffed and she's
gonna hit her face okay so we're gonna
do a technique where we more are
emphasizing
uh a seated position as a position and
disadvantage versus prone
okay
so we're here
uh you want sankyo
and you want to turn the palms down
down and it starts shifting her weight
back you see
okay and we're just gonna seat her down
on her butt
okay
um so we'll get her back up
and she starts
moving around all squarely just put it
down and she's down on her butt okay
we'll do it again
she's doing all her stuff
down on her butt okay
if they're really really strong uh we
can do this buckle i'll show it over
here
so the sakyo always going to shift
weight to the back
but if you need to you can buckle the
knee just by hitting uh pushing behind
us
the leg there and now this is a much
easier drop okay
so you can do that okay
if your partner feels the need to do it
you have to do your aikido and you gotta
i gotta go with how fast she's gonna
drop i can't be staying up here okay so
she's all swirly
that knee
down
okay
now i'll show you why we can emphasize
the seated position as a position of
disadvantage equal to the prone in this
case so handcuffed
and
unarmed okay we don't have to put him
down on the ground
right
down on the ground and everyone's
stepping on her and causing
compressional asphyxiation okay so i'll
do it with one guy but we would have two
but just to make the point with one guy
you want to try to get up and fight and
all that kind of stuff
and what's happening to you uh taking
off balance yeah you sound a little
windy yes keep going
what's happening to your energy
getting lower you're getting tired
you're getting tired and i'm not really
doing any force it will just do that
until they get tired
and then they're just sitting here
okay
yes all right
you need anything
no sir okay
until i have two people you come in are
you ready to walk to the car yes sir
okay tuck in your right foot to your
groin area there and just hold on
uh we're gonna stand up all right you're
gonna stand up on your own can you do
that yes okay here we go one two three
cool did they start getting froggy again
okay guess what you're right back in the
same thing until they get tired okay